side effects is an incredible film I
[ __ ] love this movie sure it's only
februari but I may have discovered one
of the best films of 2013 first off jus
law is amazing in it the man knows how
to internalize his emotions but remain
fully expressive at the same time Rooney
Mara is completely believable as this
woman who is suffering with clinical
depression they + on the bright side you
get a seat Rudy Mars tits yes Rudy
martes tits are in this film once again
Rooney Mars tips are in this film I
believe both actors desert Oscar nods
for their performances the directing and
writing is absolutely excellent this
should not be director Steven Soderbergh
las well it's a film that could be
conventional but it's not it's a
thriller where the thrills build with a
bunch of surprise twists mainly due to
the director allowing the actors to do
their work where fear comes from what's
this person gonna do should we trust
this person whose fault is this who's
really in the wrong here this film keeps
you on your toes you'll be on the edge
of your seat walls being emotionally
pulled into the characters and I must
mention this film looks absolutely
beautiful the sim autauga fur creates
sort of a dreamlike world which seems to
complement rooney Morrow's emotions last
but not least it's an authentic
realistic picture that is not full of
Hollywood [ __ ] the medical world
feels very authentic it feels like we're
taking a detailed glimpse into these
people's lives people are comparing to
style this film to the great Alfred
Hitchcock and it absolutely deserves
that acknowledgement there's just so
much to say that all I really have to
tell you is it's stylish it's thrilling
and it's emotionally effective just go
watch the [ __ ] movie all at all i
gotta say side effects got its super
right
you